[Music]
everybody welcome back to our city today
is a very long detailing episode since
I'll really just be adding details in
and around the airport and the highway
as well and I want so much be building
anything new as I'll just be improving
what I already had and adding extra
detailing to that kind of based on
trying to make it as realistic as
possible and lots of reference points
but also on some of the feedback that I
got in the last video so without further
ado let's get into the time lapse now
the first thing I wanted to do in this
episode was move up the runway just a
little bit and this actually ended up
creating some issues with the move it
mod as some of the paths weren't
entirely correctly moved and it also
means that I'm going to have to redo
some of the connections with the taxiway
as well though that's not too much of an
issue for a reason that I'll get back to
later on but the reason that I wanted to
move up the runway itself was really
just based on a lot of suggestions that
I got the airport itself was very tight
the runway was extremely close to the
rest of the buildings and to the taxiway
as well and especially that gap between
the taxiway in the runway was very close
so I wanted to open that up a little bit
and moving the runway wasn't too much
effort but I think it's a pretty good
improvement to the airport itself now
lots of comments also talked about the
airport being supremely close to the
rest of the city and this is something
that I just can't really fix with move
it moving the entire airport at once
would definitely cause a lot more issues
than just moving the runway and would be
pretty much impossible the reason that I
did place the airport as close to the
city as I did because I do think that I
placed it quite a bit too close to the
city this was just a miscalculation on
my part but I definitely wanted to place
it very close to the city and not even
that much less close than it is at the
moment because I just wanted to make the
travel time while the minimal amount
that I could between the city and the
airport since the idea is really that
the city heavily relies on the airport
since Road would otherwise be the only
other connection to the rest of the
country now some people also commented
that it's actually that far away
from the rest of the con of the country
either and this actually turned out to
be pretty true it only takes about 40
minutes to get from this airport to the
actual airport in the north part of
Bahrain and I actually overestimated how
large Bahrain would be literally this
Airport and Omar city in general the
idea behind the city is that it's
somewhere in the southwest of Bahrain
and with the location then I generally
sort of blend it only takes about 40
minutes to get from this part to the
other Airport which is the only place at
the moment in the country where people
are actually living so the travel times
aren't actually too bad but that said 40
minutes to another city by Road where
you could even have some traffic jams I
think does make a difference when you
could also just hop on a plane five
minutes by Metro away so I still think
it's worth it especially if you figure
from the idea of being an international
service or information economy kind of
hub especially also if you see that you
know cities like The Hague and Rotterdam
has airports as well when Amsterdam
Airport is only half an hour away from
there so I think it's still something
that I want to try and of course I also
just want to build an airport in this
game that was just something I really
wanted to try for myself so that's why I
have the airport in the city and that's
why it's so close to the rest of the
city as well just to make sure that it's
as close a public transport wise to the
rest of the city as I could make it it
also kind of still connects the airport
to the rest of the city but in hindsight
I could have had it a little bit further
away from downtown but that's there's
not really too much that I can change
about that at this point now getting
back to what I'm doing at the moment I
wanted to add some extra detailing to
the highway quite a few people commented
on the fact that the highway was very
undetailed which is a very very comments
because it was it was definitely
something I wanted to leave behind for
this episode to actually finish it up
and some of the stuff that I still
needed to do to actually make this look
like a realistic highway was aside from
just placing general foliage and the
Kal's to make it like look a little bit
more realistic nature wise I also wanted
to have some barriers on the sides and
some lights in the middle I chose to go
for these very fancy lights because many
of the highway lights are very large and
I didn't want to have something that was
too large and some of the modern lights
were just either very hard to notice or
not much special and I really wanted to
have some more decorative lights over
here in these lampposts like to me are a
little bit too big to place them inside
the city because they're quite large
I do feel they're kind of out of the
human scale but I think they fit very
well into a highway where everything
around the highway in general is always
designed to be like seen more from
speeding around there which means
everything around the highway is
generally made bigger or more stretched
out even on the highway itself so I
think these are the kinds of lights that
I really wanted to use on the highway
because they're a bit more noticeable at
those speeds and at least add a bit of a
unique sort of look to the highway as
well I'll definitely get back to the
highway detailing somewhere in during
this episode I can't actually remember
I'm I've done a lot of detailing around
the place but it will definitely be
detailed a little bit more than it is at
the moment I just wanted to get to some
of the foliage and decals on the side of
the highway as well something that I'll
be doing quite a bit around the city is
just adding decals to add some slightly
rocky correctly textures to the sand
maybe this is part laziness because I
can be bothered to find more textures to
try and test then you know I currently
did already I actually spend quite a few
hours just messing with the textures and
importing new textures for this end to
see what I actually wanted to get and
for now I just feel like the decals are
a pretty good way to kind of have some
slight variations in textures that's one
of the things that's always bugged me
about city skylines and I think the
decals are just an amazing way to get
rid of that now we've done out of the
way something else that I wanted to draw
with decals was the detailing on the
terminal side
airports this enormous concrete area
where everything's that's most important
for the airport is going to be placed
and one of the first things that I
wanted to do was to make it look as if
they're actually concrete plates that
are put in place instead of just a giant
smooth concrete field so here I just put
the lines in to make it look like
they're actually large concrete tiles
and I definitely feel that helps out a
lot because it really gives you that
Airport look a lot of airports well
pretty much all of them do really have
that sort of concrete plate look to them
at least the ones that I've been to and
I think that adds quite a bit to the
look but again I'll kind of get back to
that area as well at some points but
here I just randomly felt like going to
small parking lots and working on that a
little bit you might find then I'm
actually kind of all over the place when
it comes to detailing in this episode
but there's going to be some interesting
stuff happening on the terminal side of
things when I want to be detailing
everything in such a way that it
actually looks as though planes could be
guided around the place
and the same kind of goes for the
highway in terms of doing stuff with
curbs I wanted to try some custom curbs
but anyway I just quickly jumped to this
parking lot because it was glaringly
empty at the moment and just like
something that kind of drags you out of
the immersion of looking at the airports
and I wanted to make sure that if I get
some override shots or if I get some
pictures of the airport everything that
you see is pretty much finished so I
quickly wanted to get to that but I'll
return to that later as well because I'm
just kind of all over the place a day
now here is when I'm getting to the
curves of the highway and I thought this
was pretty interesting I've been
experimenting with this a little bit and
I couldn't really find any curbs that
work together
it was either like white yellow
combinations or all just gray and that
didn't really work out too well but I
think the yellow plus black or gray in
this case which is kind of the black
works out very well as curbs this is
something that you see quite a bit in
the Gulf area where the curve
around roads are painted and sometimes
it's like red and white but in Bahrain I
found that in a lot of places it's
yellow and black I'm not actually quite
sure what the real difference between it
is it's obviously very like obvious
colors and ones that are usually meant
to signal danger which definitely makes
it quite obvious where the ends of the
road are but that aside aside from you
know looking at the map at Street View
just checking out where you actually
find these things I haven't really
looked into why exactly curves are
painted in countries like this I just
know that it's something that the
Netherlands doesn't really do just keeps
them great but it's something that you
see around quite a bit in these
countries and I haven't really seen
anybody to try it especially not mixing
these different curves together to make
some black yellow curbs but that was
something that I quickly wanted to try
and it also just makes everything look a
little bit more fancy like this a bit
more of a neat transition going from the
asphalt of the highway to the sand
that's on the side of the highway now I
tried for a little bit to get some
different things to fill in the divider
between the two sides of the highway and
there wasn't really anything that I felt
fitting as a sense at this point there
are quite a few highway barriers then I
was thinking about using like these for
example but they all turn out to be too
lights and just have textures that
didn't really fit so in the end I just
ended up using a wall for that and just
left it at that now when we go to the
runway over here there is quite a bit of
work that I have to do here and this is
where the majority of the painting comes
in for one I wanted to lengthen the
highway I've also got a comment that you
know why would you keep the runway that
short if you've got a desert anyway that
wasn't literally what that person said
but I think it makes a little sense it's
it's something that I could just very
easily make longer I don't per se need
it and it's definitely more expensive to
have a longer highway but in case that
you do want to have jumbo planes landing
here that should now be possible I know
I wrote down the numbers
I can't exactly remember but this runway
has been lengthened to a little over two
thousand and six hundred meters I
believe yeah that's it and that was for
the Airbus 380 to land which I believe
there are a few assets in the workshop
as well and those are also some assets
that I placed so still all of the planes
that I placed are going to be able to
land on this runway it just means that
the runway is a little bit longer to
actually accommodate for some larger and
international planes as well which I
thought was also kind of funny in the
comment section there was a pretty large
discussion about me calling planes
international when they're just
medium-range planes and I guess this is
very much just a sort of ego centric
view of mine as a European where
international flights are actually very
short and with medium-range planes
because if you're in the US or a
different very large country those would
more usually be called intercontinental
but in this case I definitely meant
international claims in terms of a
medium-range so I reckon a lot of the
traffic in this place would come from
places like Qatar or Dubai United Arab
Emirates stuff like that so those planes
should definitely be good for that kind
of stuff maybe if you want to go to
different places in Asia perhaps even
Europe it could work but you know it
doesn't really matter too much because
now we can just learn big planes over
here anyway now I've been meaning to
catch up with what I've been doing on
the screen because there is some stuff
happening here I wanted to get to the
detailing of the runway and the taxiways
most of all and this took most of the
time actually because the game only
comes with a few very simple washed out
yellow lines on the middle of the
taxiways but they aren't quite realistic
and well I just really wanted to expand
on that I wasn't quite happy with how
that worked so I wanted to get in all of
the markings here now we have the yellow
marking in the middle even bitl what we
have the yellow marking in the middle
which
is pretty much always there from the
game and that's just the marking that
sort of the guide for the plaintiff you
go over which isn't too exciting then on
the sides we also have like the taxiway
edge markings which is the markings that
the plane should never ever cross that's
basically to keep the plane going in the
right position pretty much and then
between the taxiways and the large field
of concrete we also have like the iOS
holding markings which makes like
basically as far as I know it means that
that's the zone where planes shouldn't
be able to like thrive it's like the do
not move zone it's basically where all
the planes are parked to be boarded and
yeah that's that's sort of like you've
got three zones you've got like the non
movement area where the terminal is then
you've got like the taxiways and then
you've got another zone which is the
runway and for the runway as well we
have those yellow markings on the
transitions from the taxiways onto the
runway and hopefully that should all be
correct although as always I'm always
looking for feedback and critics and
anything to improve anything but this is
really as far as I found now here I
wanted to get to some of the terminal
markings because that's something that
you don't really see too often either
and it's definitely not something that
comes with City skylines so one of the
things that I wanted to get in here are
just some of those vehicle lanes
actually ended up moving those outward
because they're too close to the gates
at this point so there will in the end
only be a vehicle lane alongside the ILS
marking over here but that's basically
where all of the all of the vehicles
that you need around the airport are
going to be going and we've also got
some markings like these red ones which
are quite a bit better than the
extremely bright red markings which I
tried a little bit earlier are basically
the places where I can't find the image
word for it but where you don't want to
have like anything standing so where no
no stuff like trucks or anything else
should be because that's where your
boarding thingamajig tunnel it is as
well
and then there are some of the lines for
the plains and there are also some like
horizontal lines on the yellow lines as
well to mark like where which planes
should be stopping as far as I know and
though I have to be honest then I just
sort of randomly put those there I can
actually be bothered to check out where
exactly I had to put those lines and
even if I did I wouldn't be able to get
too many because I'm technically not
even learning that many types of planes
on this Airport now on the side and this
is a little bit awkward I have those
like boiling things the boarding bridges
but there aren't actually any flames
that can connect to it at that close of
a distance there's not the ones that I
wanted to use so I'm actually not going
to use those I wish I could you've
remove them because those are basically
just the burning areas for short
distance flights or whatever kinds of
other like small city jets or whatever
you'd want to use and we still have some
like burning bridges over there but that
came with the airport building and I'm
not too happy with happy having those
day you might have noticed that I
actually try to remove them on the other
side near the road by placing some
buildings over them which works out
quite well but only side it's it's like
a little bit of a messy thing which I'd
rather not see as for the rest of the
detailing here I'm just marking out the
areas where I'll be placing some of the
stalks like I just keep forgetting the
word for it but anyway all of the stuff
that you use around the airport all the
vehicles and all of the materials and
everything and also directly underneath
the planes I just already wanted to look
at some of the detailing in terms of
having the loading of baggage and here
oh and the toes that carry the planes
actually forgot to add some fuel like
fewer lines to it so that's something
that I might want to return to in the
future and actually get that in there
but that's just a tiny detail aside from
that most of the detailing in there is
actually something that I'm really had
and actually most happy with how the
lines turn out but also the decals I
think it adds quite a bit to make
everything not necessarily look dirty
but just have some slight variations and
how the concrete looks and also make it
look a little bit darker because
considering just how light the sand is
and how dark I wanted the runway
concrete to look I think it helps out
quite a bit to have these decals over
here and have that slightly darker look
to the concrete
especially at some points where it might
be dirty or where there might be some
cracks I think this is where the decals
really shine in ending that little last
layer of like shine it's basically that
cherry on the pie kind of elements of
detailing but it's it's always a fun and
simple thing to add I think the same
counts for the concrete as the sand it
just makes it look a lot more
interesting and realistic now finally I
wanted to get to the detailing on the
side here but I'm basically following
just about the same procedure here I'm
not entirely sure where exactly I would
place the area where people would come
out of the building because this is not
actually a terminal building that's
supposed to be left without boarding
gates but then again I'm not really too
worried about that either
it looks pretty all right and you know
if anybody has any comments or ideas on
how I could change or add to the
airport's or if it's just fine I'm
always happy to read you know get any
kind of feedback about that in any case
I'm quite happy with how it turned out
myself
something that I did want to like stay
away from a little bit was the detail
anything else
around the airport as much I think it
can be very difficult to try and move
away from detailing things or try and
move away from placing things at all but
to say in a strangely cliched way and I
think you can really notice any
detailing if there are no areas without
detailing and especially for and I
really like an airport you want to
realistically stay away from detailing
every parts and as much as it's as it
looks very fun to add all kinds of
shrubs and bushes and trees
and stuff like that around the runway I
wanted to keep it as flat as possible
and at some point I was experiencing or
experimenting with putting some grass
around it like this class I was hoping
that it would stay really low and just
kind of look like there are some weeds
or like simple stuff growing between the
runway but spoiler I actually ended up
removing all of that in the end because
I really wanted to keep this very low
not just for the reasons that you know
but the look of it I wanted to keep it
completely empty but also because areas
between runway should just be left as
empty as you can and you don't want to
end up having like animals live between
the runways or having like any kind of
hindrance from the areas between the
runways in any kind of similar fashion
so I wanted to keep that as simple as I
could while at the same time kind of
working with the decals a little bit to
at least make it like a tiny bit
interesting these are just some of the
shots there that you know looking at it
in-game at the time I was really stunned
actually at just how realistic this game
can manage to look I think the lighting
especially works wonders in this case as
well and how well the loot works for the
kind of climates that I'm going for as
well by the way I'm still just on the
realistic fee 1.2 loop and as for the
the rest of the theme there isn't really
much else to it although I do have to
say I do also use the ultimate eye candy
and as far as I know I've actually set
my global light intensity a little bit
lower and I think the same goes for the
ambient light intensity but it's not too
much of a difference I think the
majority of how this map looks basically
comes from the mixed themes which I know
I have gotten quite a few questions
about this but I'm extremely sorry I
can't actually share any different theme
for this map because it doesn't have a
theme I just mixed themes together in
the D mixer and I believe there still
are some custom textures in there as
well and I think that in combination
the realistic view 1.2 kind of gives the
entire thing its look that's said by the
way I still got quite a few comments
about sharing a mod and a setlist
about this city and I kind of feel bad
about that because I update that almost
every day and I put a lot of work into
making sure that it's updated but I just
forgot to put it in the description for
the last couple of times so that's
that's a pretty bad thing going on there
so I'll be putting that in the
description of this video and if I don't
forget hopefully also in the
descriptions of upcoming videos if I
don't put it in there feel free to call
me out on it and I'll put it in the
description so here I wanted to get
through some of the detailing of the
other areas that also need some love
basically for this Airport in general
there are a few areas where you've got
the main terminal and the places where
you're bored I've got a couple of
hangars over here I'm sure if that's
actually how I pronounce it but yeah
I've got a couple of like storage
buildings over here I guess that works
where you know it's just general storage
area there will also be a distribution
center for DHL that was KLM at first but
I think it's a little bit more realistic
to have DHL over here and there are
plenty of really good DHL assets for
that kind of stuff so that's why I
figured to go with DHL in the end and
there's also going to be a small fuel
loading station with a couple of like
fuel things and finally there's going to
be a heliport although I'm not quite
going to add too much to that in this
episode they're really strangely enough
you know this is this was a ridiculously
long time that's already and I even
managed to cut out some pieces I still
didn't finish the airport in this
episode so I'm not entirely sure what
I'm going to do with that so I'm just
going to add finishing the airport to
the next episode but yeah sadly I
haven't been able to finish it yet
that's just too much detailing going on
at the moment although some of the
detailing like the detailing over here
is really just adding all kinds of
industrial details to these backstage
areas to make it like look like they're
actually proper areas and
just standalone buildings and really
make these these backstage areas come to
life as well I think no assets like this
the tiny details don't really matter too
much in the general look of the city but
just in making it feel as if it's a
light and as if it's actually a
functioning real city a different thing
kind of goes to the decals and
decorations around the highway here
because I definitely wanted to have give
a good look to this part of the highway
by adding all of the foliage and decals
around these buildings because in the
end this is also kind of the entrance
into the city these are some of the
first buildings that you see around the
side of the highway so the the office
buildings here kind of form a bit of a
sort of wall around the highway on both
sides and kind of line them for pretty
quick access to the road but also to the
airport and to just be a sort of fancy
highway skilled area to enter in I think
the thing about this is that you know
architecture around highways like office
architecture especially is never really
going to be too interesting but I think
it fits around a highway like this
because it's it's not too much in a
human city scale as well and you'd
rather want to have buildings like these
on the edge of your city around your
highway then in the middle taking in the
middle of your city taking up an entire
city book where there could be some more
smaller interesting buildings well you
know that's just a personal thing that's
something I kind of feel about it though
so that's why I wanted to put these very
strictly obviously boring office
buildings on the side of the city on the
edge here alongside the highway along
with some general foliage to make it
look like it's not a completely boring
desert or has somebody make the pun in
the last comment section Bahrain desert
but actually there's there's quite a bit
of foliage and grass in there as well as
if it's some dunes kind of area
now here I got to the DHL area very
quickly but I didn't really add too much
to it yet just some basic ideas of what
I'm going to do with that later on I did
want to add some of these concrete
plates again though just to make it look
like it's actually a proper set of
concrete tiles instead of just a large
field of concrete and then I wanted to
get to quickly setting up the heliport
area in a very similar sense because I
had the concrete tiles at this point
anyway now as far as I know the reason
that airports sometimes have heliports
as well is because I believe helicopters
even though they can in many situations
just I get up in in a vertical way
sometimes they would actually just need
to have use the runway as well for a
sort of standard takeoff so having them
besides a runway is actually a bit of a
handy thing I'm not sure if there are
any helicopter experts who could chime
in on that but that's basically the
reason why I put a heliport on the side
of this as well and even if it wasn't
the reason I would have no idea where
else to put a heliport and this is just
for any kind of type of helicopter which
you might only use around our city so
it's just a bit of a an edit facility to
the airport in that sense and I thought
it was an interesting extension for the
airport so you can see that the airport
essentially getting used quite a bit at
this point so at once that's pretty nice
on the other hand I've noticed that
sometimes airports start getting stuck
in the middle of the sky after taking
off I'm not quite sure why you might
have noticed it by shadows or maybe some
parts in the cinematic shots in the
beginning of the end of the video but
yeah I'm not sure why but planes start
flying in circles in the middle of the
sky and I've kind of have to get the
advance to your coops and actually get
those things out of there but until I do
we're pretty much can have to deal with
those things being stuck there that's a
little bit unfortunate but aside from
that I guess it's good to see that the
airport is actually getting used one of
my initial wealth fairs was really that
the airport would get used whatsoever
something that I was very afraid of with
the population of the city being not
that high but I'm glad that at least
airplanes are using it quite a bit
now as for some simple detailing around
the heliport there's just some parking
spaces around here for whoever want to
work or use the heliport same kind of
goes for most of the other facilities
the fuel loading station has some
general basic parking spots and also
some parking spots for the shell fuel
trucks that are going to get in there
and basically all of the industrial
areas have their own parking spots
that's all quite simple and nothing out
of the ordinary there I also wanted to
divide it in a very similar way with
some sensors and decals and some general
industry or detailing to make sure that
they actually all kind of looks alive a
little bit and I ended up doing the same
over here that said I didn't end up
detailing things too much I didn't want
to go too in detail because I still kind
of feel like I want to give everything a
similar level of detailing and this can
sometimes be a bit of a difficult thing
to think about usually or very often I
think the way people build cities and
the way that it's probably best to do it
is to just get a general layout done and
kind of focus on two most important
areas and in areas that you definitely
want to look at and detail those so to
take for instance Chrome's McGee series
which I know I've shouted out recently
before but it's really cool to see how
he's doing like all kinds of
intersections so yeah definitely check
out his link below in the description
but he for example makes them extremely
detailed intersections in some places
and at all kinds of detail small parts
of cities but just the general layout of
a city is often just left in general
because there's no way that you can
detail every single part of a city and
in almost 50 I kind of want to reach a
balance between that I don't go to
extremely detailed that I'm like adding
separate objects for every square meter
of the city or for every square meter
report of the city but at the same time
I do
and some detailing that if you zoom in
on the city it still looks like it's a
real city so I'm trying to kind of hit
the balance between enough detailing
where it actually kind of looks real and
there's some interesting detailing going
on in the entire city while at the same
time not too much detailing that it
becomes impossible to have the same
level of detail around the entire city
and I think this is just a bit of an
approach thing I just personally like
you know getting into that immersion of
having every part of the city have about
the same level detailing but that's just
something that I quite like about it you
can actually see the planes kind of
flying in a weird curve over there it's
very strange
I'm not quite sure why it happens I've
seen quite a few threads on the internet
of people having the same issue but at
the moment are not quite sure how to fix
it
there doesn't seem too much of fix in
place except for just getting advanced
vehicle options and removing those
things I was actually really surprised
by the way how much just adding a couple
of ferns and trees added to the sides of
the runway I didn't want to really add
any advanced foliage besides two runways
themselves or in-between the wrong way
and the taxiways not quite sure why I'm
talking about the runway as plural but I
didn't want to put like some simple
foliage around the sides of the
buildings at the airport because doesn't
really matter too much but I think it
gives you a bit of a nicer transition
from some of the buildings into the
empty spaces of the runway and actually
quite glad with how that all turned out
now it's the very final part of this
episode I wanted to get to the other
side of the highway and kind of add some
detailing to that it's not quite as much
as I would like in the end so I might
get back to this as well and actually
play some cars on those parking spots
not sure why nobody is using them but
they look really sad empty like that so
that's something that I definitely might
want to fix but for now I just want to
get some simple trees in some planters
and make sure that it all looks a little
bit more interesting by getting some
decals in place as well
now that's almost it for this video I'll
just be ending this with a bit more
detailing around the highway in terms of
gangs and foliage and decals in but
you've probably already seen quite a bit
of that and with some of the final
touches to this area I would like to end
this video so thank you guys for
watching and staying through this
ridiculously long time lapse hopefully
it'll be a little bit shorter next time
that's also a little bit more doable for
me as well to be perfectly honest and
half an hour episodes are simply not
something that I'm entirely aiming for
but for now this is basically when I
have for this episode and I wanted to
get it out as much as I can anyway so
yeah thanks for watching and I hope to
see you guys
[Music]
you
[Music]